Avez vous déjà fait par le passé quelque chose que vous regrettez amèrement actuellement
Comme faire tomber cet objet !
Eh bien moi oui
Et encore mieux il s'agissait de vidéos sponsorisées !
Vos vidéos préférées finalement
Les gens se plaignent encore beaucoup des youtubeurs qui travaillent avec les marques
Alors oui des fois ça donne des vidéos de merde mais des fois ça donne des trucs cools
Et aujourd'hui, j'vais vous montrer ce que ça donne quand ça donne des vidéos de merde
Vous avez peut être déjà vu ce que je vais vous montrer là
En tout cas sachez que... pendant des années les gens se sont amèrement moqués de moi dans le YouTube game
Pour avoir osé participer à ces choses
C'est parti !
La vidéo de la honte, la première attention !
Ça s'appelle... * Bruit de touches de clavier * Clash Food
C'est une série de vidéos sponsorisées
J'crois que j'avais touché euh 500 €
À savoir pile ce qu'il fallait pour acheter une XBOX ONE à sa sortie
Ou une PS4 plus un appartement, je sais pas !
Regardez on l'a on l'a tous fait, on est tous des grosses merdes !
Parce que je m'humilie mais j'humilie quand même les gens qui l'ont fait après moi dans le doute hein
NewTiteuf, VodKprod, SebLaFrite remember les gars remember
On va regarder un peu ensemble parce ce que je sais que vous avez envie d'être d'être très mal à l'aise
Et après j'vais vous expliquer pourquoi je m'suis fait douiller
Moi c'était contre DarkFuneral c'est parti
" Squeezie, DarkFuneral bienvenue dans Clash Food l'émission qui clash et qui food "
*Ouaiiiis*
Squeezie : J'vais te clasher
DarkFuneral : On pari ?
Squeezie : C'est ça ouais
*bruit de touche espace**Malaise*
Ça fait mal, ça brûle ça brûle l'intestin
Et pour une fois, c'est pas le Coca qui brûle c'est la honte
Aah, j’étais bien bien puceau
"On dit de lui que c'est le Gamer le plus taré du Net, en cuisine,
rien ne l'arrête"
Voici , Squeezie
*Claquement de doigt* Heyyyyy
C'est surjoué c'est nul pff c'est horrible
"Tu vas devoir cuisiner une Pizza trash au chèvre pour ton pote DarkFuneral"
Et ben il va bien manger l'fufu
*Rire*
"Mais pas si longtemps
Car on va t'infliger un handicap cher Squeezie"
Squeezie : D'accord
"Et oui, sinon ça serait trop facile"
*Il sent quelque chose*
Vous sentez la douille arriver là ?
Hein !
Pour vous expliquer un peu, on m'a dit que j'allais faire une vidéo originale avec un Youtuber de mon choix
Tout en étant payé pour ça
Donc j'étais content, j'me disais "ouais mais on va faire quoi exactement ?"
Et il m'avais dit "bah tu vas devoir cuisiner dans des circonstances rigolotes"
Par exemple tu vas devoir cuisiner du poisson au milieu
d'une horde de chats qui sont donc beaucoup attirés
par ce que tu cuisines. C'est la phrase qui m'avait convaincu (rire)
Je m'en souviens mon gars, c'était il y a trois ans,
je m'en souviens totalement, j'avais donc accepté en me disant : putain
ça va être hyper marrant, on va trop s'amuser ça va être
original, cool...
Ouvrez bien vos narines,
il faut la sentir la douille. - hé je suis un mec gentil
- Oui, et bien tu vas cuisiner,
avec ton visage.
...BAM ! OH ! OH !..
OH ! Voilà, je ne savais...
Et DarkFuneral non plus ne savait pas,
que nous allions devoir cuisiner avec notre visage !
Maintenant Mesdames et Messieurs, j'aimerais un silence complet
pour faire place au moment le plus malaisant
de l'histoire de ma chaîne youtube
- *bruit étrange*...alors attends - oui voilà
c'est ça
*bruits de bouche*
*bruits de nez et de bouche*
*il crache sur la pizza*
Al dente Señorita !
*malaise*
*applaudissements*
Bravo les amis, Bravo !
Grâce à vous ce fils de p*te a maintenant sept millions d'abonnés
BRAVOOOO ! Bravoo !
Al dente Seño...Ta gueule, ferme ta gueule.
INSUPPORTABLE !
Vous trouvez mes cris et ma voix qui mue constamment insupportable
Mais le Squeezie de cette vidéo est cent fois pire, putain.
Et ça se termine par DarkFuneral qui goûte ma pizza.
Voilà.
C'est...
Très bien...
très bien
très bien, très bien, très bien
J'avais mis un pouce bleu ?*bruits de souris*
C'est bon, il y est c'est sûr ?
Vraiment... Non mais j'insiste.
"Ceux qui regardent en 2015 lèvent la main"
Bah soyez pas fiers ! Soyez pas fiers.
Baissez la vraiment bas votre main.
Bon R.I.P à tous ceux qui l'ont fait derrière en sachant ce que c'était
Les gars je vous pardonnerais jamais
Attends il y a beaucoup de Seb la frite sur cette chaîne hein ?
Ah ça aimait faire de la vidéo de qualité hein Seb !*rire*
C'est maintenant l'heure du deuxième truc que je regrette le plus au monde
Un mois avant Clash Food on avait été contacté pour tourné une sorte de
mini court-métrage
de plusieurs épisodes où c'était une parodie de
Splash, l'émission de TF1 j'crois.
Pareil, on était payé,
J'avais touché je crois 1000 euros
Donc c'était énorme ! Moi j'étais encore au lycée mon gars !
J'étais refait.
En plus je voyais surtout ça comme un projet cool, des vidéos marrantes
qui changent un peu de ce qu'on fait d'habitude
Ah bah ça changeait ouais...
C'était d'la MERDE !!!
OOOOOH ! Bah regardez qui est là, Jeremy.
T'es content d'être dans cette vidéo Jeremy ?
Tu peux parler de tes regrets vas-y, vas-y c'est à toi vas-y
Déjà...
Déjà juste avec ce générique tu sais
T'aurais dû cliquer sur autre chose.
Bon je vais juste vous mettre mon passage parce que c'est ça qui nous intéresse
mais en gros, c'était un concours...euh de plat.
Il fallait faire le plus beau plat possible
Et comme c'était il y a trois ans ce corps
que vous traitez de lâche. Eh ben il y a trois ans c'était
un corps de de traitre ! Un corps de haute trahison mon gars !
*malaise*
*malaise encore*
c'est douloureux x2
-Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie
ou plutôt... Lucas
et d'habitude j'aime bien faire des podcasts et des vidéos
sur les jeux, dans lesquels je dis
beaucoup de conneries vraiment nazes. Aujourd'hui
je vais devoir relever un challenge vraiment
très très important de...
J'suis pas du tout à l'aise là.
c'est scandaleux ce qui se passe !
Alors moi la piscine ca m'évoque plutôt des maladies
style mycose et verrues, euh...
des trucs qui trucs qui puent en fait.
-J'ai pissé dans l'eau ! (rire)
Je revendique cette blague !
Pour moi la piscine c'est un lieu dans lequel il est possible
de rencontrer Bob l'éponge. Mais malheureusement
je l'ai...Oh p*tain tu l'as trouvé !
Je revendique cette blague !
Bon alors Squeezie tu connais le principe, hein, tu connais le
principe ! Il faut affronter ses peurs et faire le plus grand plouf.
Eh ben tu t'éclates à faire des vidéos sur le net, et ben maintenant
c'est dans l'eau que tu vas t'éclater. Ok ?T'es prêt ? Tu l'as déjà fait.
T'es prêt. T'es prêt. Tu connais ça, allez Squeezie.
On y va. Allez !
(musique épique)
On nous avait quand même promis dans le contrat de voir sauter des meufs en bikini
*cri*
Mais ? Andyraconte. T'es contente de passer dans ma vidéo ?
(rire)
(re-musique épique)
Je fais des conneries dans mes videos mais la... ffff.
c'est du lourd quoi ! Ouais c'est du lourd comme tu joues le comédien Lucas.
-(Cortex) eh Squeezie fais direct ton plat comme ca  nous fera direct gagner du temps, mon pote hein.
-(Squeezie) Ouais c'est ca Cortex !
-(Seb la frite ) Il est meilleur aux jeux vidéo -(Aziatomik) Ouais carrément mec.
Blague revendiquée par Seb la frite !
Three...two....one ! Go !
*Il saute*
Plouf !!!
(rires de Cortex, Seb la frite et Aziatomik)
-Il avait raison !
(rires)
Ah p*tain
mec c'est tellement des regrets énormes,
je vous jure que on m'a trollé pendant longtemps
à cause de ça mec. Pendant très longtemps !
Allez c'est l'heure du dernier regret, hein ! Parce que
jamais 2 sans 3 ! *bruits de clavier*
ahhh. Ca c'est dur. Ça c'est une parodie
des anges de la téléréalité, mais encore plus nulle que
le vrai programme des anges de la téléralité qui est déjà
bien nul à chier. Donc c'était 3 mois après clashfood
Ah c'était un grosse année. 2013 ça y'allait hein !
On était présent hein !!! Donc ouais il y avait une villa
et y avait un scénario tout claqué,
et y avait plusieurs épisodes et chaque épisode suivait le
point de vue d'une personne diférente. Tiens ben regardez Seb la frite
avait la coupe de Justin Bieber a l'époque.
EH OH C'EST QUI QU'A PAS TIRÉ LA CHASSE ?
C'EST QUI QU'A PAS TIRÉ LA CHASSE ?
OUHOUH C'EST QUI QU'A PAS TIRÉ LA CHASSE ?
À peine ça commence et c'est déjà
nul ! C'est incroyable !
-(Kelly) Je passe devant les toilettes et comme d'habitude, la chasse d'eau qui n'est pas tirée.
Mais franchement c'est trop dégueu quoi.
Je suis sûre que c'est toi squeezie. MAIS VAS-Y
JE SAIS QUE C'EST TOI QUI N'AS PAS TIRÉ LA CHASSE POURQUOI TU N'ASSUME PAS ?
-(Squeezie) Sérieux arrête je te le dirais !
Gnagnagna qui a pas tiré la chasse d'eau
et gnagnagna ... Mais ma petite Kelly, je vais tirer autre chose moi.
ahahah.
*applaudissements*
Voilà c'était mon rôle
dans cette vidéo je jouais le pervers de la vidéo.
A présent je vais cacher ma honte derrière ces lunettes dernière génération.
-(Kelly) Tu tires pas la chasse assume non ? -(Squeezie) mais est ce que c'est moi ....
-(Kelly) mais t'as tiré la chasse ou pas ?
- (Squeezie) Et là Wartek sa console se transforme en
(Non d'une arme incompréhensible)
*cri* le scénario, alors la x2
on appelle Hollywood. Oui allo ? Oui
on a un scénario hors du commun ! La console s'est transformée en gun, mais c'est ca !
Combien ? 10 millions le budget ? Mais c'est ca.
C'est de la merde.
-(Kelly) Non je te lache pas ! *tir*
*tir*
- (Squeezie) Bam ! Gros shoot dans Kelly.
- (Kelly) Et là Wartek normal il me tire dessus.
(musique épique)
-(Squeezie) C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Oscarisé en 2014.
*faux applaudissements*
-(Squeezie) Je regarde le corps de Kelly et là, là ...
il se désintègre en particules dans l'air comme ca ...
C'est le meilleur moment de la vidéo.
Voir quelqu'un partir en particules, voilà.
Même la vidéo pourrait partir en particules, moi j'kifferais.
Aah ouais, moment pervers c'est parti.
-(Squeezie) Et Anna... Est devant moi en sous-vêtements, comme ça.
-(Anna) Et là j'me retourne, et qui je vois ?
-(Squeezie) C'est moiii !
Oscarisé en 2015.
-(Squeezie) Une seule idée en tête, j'lui propose qu'on parte en beauté.
-(Anna) Ah tu veux qu'on s'maquille ?
-(Squeezie) *imite la voix d'Anna* Tu veux qu'on s'maquille ? *voix normale* Nan mais franchement.
J'crois qu'en plus le pire c'est que ...
Le pire... le pire c'est qu'elle joue mieux que moi ! *rire*
Elle est carrément meilleure actrice !
-(Squeezie) Nan nan nan nan, fais pas ça, fais pas ça s'te plait !
*musique de défaite*
- (Anna) Oups! J'me suis tirée dessus. Faudrait ptêtre qu'on m'apprenne à tirer du bon sens.
Bon ok j'retire ce que je viens de dire.
-(Squeezie) Bon écoute déjà c'est moi qui ai une arme c'est moi qui parle.
-(Jérémy) Oui.
-(Squeezie) Tu arrête ! *COIN* qu'est ce que...
-(Squeezie) C'est quoi ce bordel ?
-(Jérémy) Et bim, ça s'transforme en canard
-(Squeezie) Et j'me retrouve avec un canard dans la main.
*bruit de vibration*
Allo ? Ah vous annulez la production du film ?
Ah cette vanne vous a pas convaincu ? Hm.. Starfoullah ouais.
*bruits d'explosions* *cri*
Voilà ! C'était euh...
Les plus grandes erreurs de ma carrière de Youtuber.
Si vous saviez comme ça m'a hanté pendant longtemps d'avoir participé à ces trucs là
parce que en fait c'est toujours dur de te projetter dans une vidéo quand t'as juste un script
ou même des fois juste une phrase comme l'histoire des chats et du poisson là,
alors qu'en vrai la vidéo c'était pas du tout ça !
Alors voilà j'me suis pris une vraie douille !
Mais là j'avais le scénario, j'savais ce que c'était etc et j'ai quand même accepté
Et... j'ai tellement mal fait j'ai très très honte.
Après j'étais jeune donc j'm'en veux pas voilà
on a tous fais des erreurs, nombreux sont là, SebLaFrite et tout *rit*
Donc si vous êtes sur Youtube peu importe depuis combien de jours, années semaines ou mois jm'en fous,
réfléchissez bien à ce que vous faites.
N'acceptez pas des choses par politesse.
Osez dire non !
*rit* Allez à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien,
C'était mes erreurs de Youtubeur.
Ciao tout le monde,
PEACE !